i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna say
doesn't this all seem familiar
no no hold on hold on what happened in
september of 2016.
emails yeah what happened with a laptop
in september of 2016.
good point anthony fbi yeah fbi and
anthony weiner
and what images did they find on his
laptop
underage messages or something yeah
what narrative was emerging against
trump
russia i tell you man the writers of
2020
are bored they run out of ideas they're
like
can we just do like a a like a total can
we do a duo you know what it is it's a
do-over it's a total do-over
honestly what if that's what it is a
total do-over and they're like we'll do
it but
this time we're gonna do everything the
exact same but this time trump loses
right
we're gonna flip we're gonna flip we're
gonna flip who we're gonna flip the
um the people that we believe and we're
gonna flip who wins the election
it's just i think what gets me and this
is why it keeps happening and the reason
i feel so familiar is
there was no accountability we never had
any accountability right even now
looking back we can know that these
things were
wrong they were malicious they were lies
all of these people still have jobs
none of it like none of these people
have lost the columns that they have
right like unless they're you know
revealing themselves on zoom these days
like it is impossible for these guys
to to lose their job or face any sort of
professional repercussions so why
wouldn't it happen again why wouldn't
they jump at the next quickest
easiest thing that might look like
russian disinformation to one
unnamed source at the fbi maybe that you
didn't bet anyway you know the secret of
media
if you write a shocking and bombastic
fake news article like it's a million
views
you make money if you then retract it
you make
more money on the retraction although
the retraction makes you substantially
less
you still put ads on the retraction page
yeah so these people know if they put
out fake news
they still get paid and so they're
incentivized
the economic incentive is to pump out
fake news and i love it when journalists
go like
well i take issue with that there's no
real reason for journalists to
to lie that way well maybe real
journalists but today you just have
people desperate for followers on
twitter yeah
so they're they're all posting the same
jokes they're all posting this like
you know what's interesting is that
these journalists live in new york
so they're surrounded by progressive
activists right
they want to fit in with the cool kids
so they just say whatever it is the cool
kids say
now that journalists are just losers
trying to desperately pander to the
popular you know influence or whatever
journalists should not try to be
influencers yes but they're trying to be
so we're politicians of course right but
i worry too
i agree they definitely are but this
this to me also gets back a little bit
to the emails thing where when dems like
when when adam schiff and chris murphy
get up there and say oh this is russian
disinformation there's a part of me
that's like
okay like they're they're they're
political hacks this is what's gonna
happen
i think it's a lot a lot worse and once
upon a time i think we all held a much
higher bar
for journalists and reporters to do that
it's one thing when you've got a lefty
politician who runs in and says
i want to fit in with the cool
progressive kids at that trendy bar in
brooklyn
and it's another one you have someone
whose sole occupation it is
to bring you something that should be a
good approximation of the truth right
the first rough draft of history
is what's in the hands of the media and
so when they're the ones who are
crafting that narrative and they're
chasing the the like retweet if you
agree
types of types of retweets for
progressives it ends up
it's so much more corrosive i think to
our body politic when they do that
because the power
and the influence that they have to be
able to pull in other people who aren't
necessarily partisans
is is a lot more dramatic and so to me
someone like
like yamiche is way more dangerous and
damaging
yeah yeah yeah yeah explain oh sorry
the chief dc correspondent for npr who
is someone who gets paid an enormous
amount of money
to be very popular on twitter and to
largely be indistinguishable
from any progressive activist who you
could imagine but what happens is
when you have people who are progressive
activists who are masquerading as
someone who is meant to bring you the
truth
i think that corrosive influence is way
way more
difficult to the most of us than a
democrat doing it i just want everybody
to realize for two seconds
ask yourself how much money do you make
doing your job
now i want you to go to glassdoor.com
and
look up writer at buzzfeed and vox and
vice
suppress and then when your blood boils
channel that energy
into a pot of tea and boil that water
and pour yourself a nice glass and sit
back and relax and just realize what
this world really is yeah yeah do it
tomorrow morning actually
don't do it before bed you'll get really
wow yeah i agree that journalism's doing
that is nasty but i
hate lying under oath when politicians
lie under oath or people on our
government-lined earth like james
clapper
saying that they were not wittingly
spying on the u.s uh
people oh totally yeah and they let him
off and he hasn't been punished for
lying under oath for committing purchase
no justice that's the justice system in
the united states so
if we're not adhering to the justice
system they're going to keep breaking
the law
yeah bro it's a big club and you ain't
in it i i think these people
these people no these people are allowed
to break the law you're not let me in
what do you mean
how why are they allowed to break the
law because the big club and you ain't
in it buddy that's just a mockery of the
system
of course but they're they're above the
law so we have the best system even
though it's terrible
we have problems because for too long
the american people have went
i'm just going to click dear r and walk
away and not have any idea who i'm
voting for
and you end up with 30-year pelosi and
30-year schumer
and 47-year biden and they don't care
about you
george carlin man that's the guy i grew
up listening to they don't
care about you they're millionaire
[ __ ] who don't care about you
that's that's what he said yep yeah and
he's right and like cia
people 40 years how long has brennan
been in the ever
ever and that's that's the thing too
like even if even if you want to look at
it and like the people who who go into
politics for the right reason or
whatever which
to be clear very very few i would
imagine do this like uh on the whole of
someone who lives in rand paul
yeah exactly it's like the only guy as
someone who lives in dc
it does seem like there's there's a
certain set of personality
characteristics that tends to draw
someone to politics and most of them
aren't good things
but even if you want to take with the
best of intentions for a lot of these
people
year one year two fine 30 years in 40
years in
you know you've got a new book you've
got to write every year that will make
you a couple hundred grand
and you've got tv shows and you've got
people to not piss off
and so that's what's happening and
you're right it's no different
unfortunately in
so many different you know the the wide
and sprawling bureaucracy be it within
intelligence or otherwise
it's the same thing it's the same people
the same jaded sorts of personalities
who have been here forever and have no
interest in in changing or learning a
new set of rules
and right now they're benefiting from
all the rules yeah didn't used to be uh
was it like that in the beginning i
don't know i mean i wasn't around i
assume you guys weren't around two
hundred years ago
did they didn't have tournaments though
back then you were definitely yeah yeah
vampire yeah yeah so walking the earth
for eight hundred years in 1790
they didn't have term limits ever right
people could just
well this was the beauty of it right so
they don't have them no i know
once once upon a time it was they you
know i think this was this was back
before it was a particularly lucrative
career to be in to be in politics right
and so i think part of the problem is
you've got people who like there are
plenty of people who
are lobbyists or otherwise connected to
the dc ecosystem who get paid
lots and lots of money to be former
politicians or to be former staffers or
whatever it is
and so once upon a time it wasn't a
particularly sexy or
or desirable sort of job and occupation
to have it certainly didn't pay the
bills and now it's become something that
is
a producer of wealth and power and
influence and so people
the people who are looking for those
three things are drawn to it like a moth
to the flame
when uh when these people get into
congress
if they lose or they leave they still
retain access
security like access to the hill and
stuff like that making it very very easy
for them to be lobbyists
yeah so that's why it was actually aoc
and ted cruz i think both
like we're teaming up on a bill yeah to
to kind of shut down this
politician to lobbyist pipeline i don't
know if they're successful on it but my
respect to both of them for for working
on that
i think i think it's you know aoc is
interesting because she
is an influencer and i i feel like she's
using
her position to become famous and i
think i feel like she's personally more
interested in fame than she is the
office
with that being said i can definitely
give her tremendous praise and credit
for working with ted cruz on a couple
things notably
that one in particular and i think term
limits too was part of it that sounds
right so
look i can be critical of somebody but i
definitely want to give respect in that
regard
i hope we get to some you know at some
point figure out how to stop
these these the issue is that they found
a way to make money
right to become wealthy of being in
office and so anything we can do to end
that pipeline where
you become a politician and then
immediately get access to being
to being wealthy that's a serious
problem we can cut their salaries
no but even then that's the solution
what the heck but even if we cut their
sales it's only 174 for congress
yeah like it doesn't need to be their
full-time job they what how many times
do they meet a week like twice or three
times a week and they could do it
remotely
it could be me doing disagreement
there's there's so much that has to go
into they're supposed they're supposed
to be doing work in their communities
right helping people and then
representing them to the federal
government
some of these people don't do that but
you got to understand a lot of the rank
and file
uh you know people in congress they do
yeah yeah
they're i think it's what half of
congress are super wealthy
something like that i mean i think some
of it just depends on how you call super
wealthy right you have to be fabulously
wealthy to run
for office these days that's an enormous
expense you also like
if you are a normal person you who can't
just like leave their job for an
extended period of time to go have a
daily once with running for
office then then it's tough but yeah i
think i think you make a good point i
think for a lot of people
a lot of people who who tend to get
reelected particularly people in their
first i don't know call it eight to ten
years
they get reelected because the people
who they come into contact with
see them as actually fighting for their
communities whether or not that's true i
think
there are a lot of people who are good
at making it seem like that's the case
um and so a lot of the good ones right
and i do think that there are good ones
are are doing that they're pounding the
pavement back home they're they're
collecting signatures whatever the hell
it is
but there are so many people who don't
have to do that nancy pelosi mitch
mcconnell
like people on our side too like they
don't have to do that everyone knows who
they are they don't have to keep working
so hard
and so to me the bigger issue is when
you've got someone like a ted kennedy
who's been in office their entire life
and everyone knows who they are and
likes who they think they might be
then they can coast and then they can
skate how does nancy pelosi keep winning
it's it's not just her but i mean mitch
mcconnell too i'm not a fan of
either of these parties i find them all
to be
the the only reason the republican party
in my opinion gets any kind of past this
point is because trump took a
sledgehammer to the republican party
and he and he chased out a bunch of the
the crony politicians who like
what several dozen have retired many
others are just like
pathetically trying to maintain some
kind of semblance of actually caring
about
the american people right yeah and i
mean i think for
for a lot of them it really did upset
the apple card they had an idea of what
they needed to do to get by and skate by
in congress an idea of how the system
worked they knew who the the good guys
were and the bad guys knew they had to
play off and play kate
and for for so long they got so it was
so easy and so comfortable to be able to
do that
and the idea like i think one of the
things getting back to your question
about you know the founding of this
country
the idea of a career politician someone
who's going to spend their entire
life running for office and holding
office and running for office again and
holding office again
that didn't exist you had people who
were part-time farmers or part-time
whatever and they would come in and
they'd
i don't know they'd take their horse to
dc or whatever it was and then they go
back home and it was
a lot it was a lot easier and so now you
have people who like this is their life
this is their lifestyle in a way that's
the system was never designed to do
something like this and it's it's even
more poorly designed today because of
the amount of money so we need to
redesign it
i think term limits are essential
congressional term limits
maybe but the challenge is that uh in
congress getting on committees and
leading committees require seniority so
this is all part of that that's fine you
can learn that in two months i think
that's it no no no
use but it's it's that it's the because
of the way the hierarchies are ordered
people who are more senior are put on
individual committees based on their
maybe we get rid of it yeah that's the
thing i think i think if you want to if
you want to have a system change there's
a lot more tearing down that needs to
happen right definitely it's term limits
you've really got to you can pull back a
lot of the layers think about something
like this like
you and your friends are all hanging out
and you're like we need to figure out
who's going to be the person to go pick
up the beer
and then you're like okay who who's
doing it someone first has to volunteer
to be
you know i'll i'll go get the beer like
do we go do you guys want james to do it
all right james it's all you
yeah that's kind of what it used to be
like you know you'd have this community
of like back in the day probably a
couple thousand people if that somewhere
is probably even less
and they'd be like who wants to go down
there and tell them what we're doing and
it would be like hey bill will you go
down there and tell them that we're
growing corn and stuff like okay
and he would go down and be like yo so
we're you know we're growing corn we got
a bunch of people it's really great
here's what we need from you guys
you know because we got banditos coming
by and so you know we need someone to
come by
and it was really like personal personal
and personable now it's like
there's too many people
have you ever seen one of the the
original drafts of the bill of rights
where like one of the first amendments
was the limit on how many
uh people a congress person could
represent oh yeah it would have been it
would have been 50 000 people
right per congress person and what that
means is today we'd have i think what
like 6 000
people in congress instead we have 435
yeah because we
now now one person represents seven
hundred thousand that's impossible so so
it right so you look at look at
ocasio-cortez's district
she ends up winning again even though
she's not
good if you look at her record i
understand she's she's a she's a
freshman with
she's she's limited experience and
understanding of the political space and
and the world but she didn't even do
anything like the bills she co-sponsored
was like renaming a post office yeah
exactly
and and all she's she's she's been
really really good at making herself a
celebrity
right getting 400 000 concurrent viewers
on on twitch playing among us
right celebrity and hey meant more power
to her congratulations she's really good
at playing that game but when it comes
to politics she hasn't done anything
other than botching the green new deal
and talking about farting cows
she's really good at generating negative
press for the party you would think
anyone who was a democrat would be like
michelle cruz cabrera was way better
because she was competent mature and
understood how the system worked
but they just wanted celebrity we got a
lot of problems with how our system
works
and right now one of the issues is if
you're someone who knows how to play the
media
you will exactly and that's and one of
the things she's done with her staff too
is she's invested very heavily in the
comms
function rather than investing in like
traditionally like you'll have a number
of las and a number of people in your
office who run policy
but if all you're trying to do is score
retweets and score positive articles and
build
you know the best relationships you can
with the editors at vanity fair so you
can get a new puff piece every couple of
months
then you're going to allocate the amount
of money that they all get to staff
their offices
and throw all of it to comms and throw
all of it to digital and find a way to
make sure that you are getting the
positive supportive stories that you
need
they're get they're going to keep you in
the public's attention in the public eye
and keep building that celebrity status
and that rock star status that she's
been able to do what has she done for us
nothing what what what has policy done
for us what has any of these people done
for us
fran paul rand paul's cool that guy
yeah i know he's the only person right
there's a couple people
you know maybe we're just expecting too
much
from these people but 400 people
there's like 350 million of us 328
yeah 435 kind congress 100 senators
no no no i disagree i disagree ian i
think that these people were hired to do
a job that they are not doing
they're failing i think they need to be
fired i think we need to start again
and i don't know how to do that and i
think that he's right i think that drew
is right i think that we need to come up
with solution
to actually fix it there are many layers
that we could go into we could go into
term limits that's the easiest thing to
go off of that's
definitely not the only thing so we
should look at what it takes to fix this
i'm not confident term limits solve the
problem either you know why no it
doesn't that's what i'm saying what will
happen is you'll have some dude
who's like okay i'm funding person a for
this
first run then once their run is expired
i have person b
training and and being ready to go and
they all work for me
oh so what do you i mean it's probably
that way and still it's probably still
that way for a lot of people
owners definitely donate special
interest and stuff
i don't i don't know how you solve the
problem i do think there's a solution
to how we do better but i i don't know
what it is
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we
go live don't forget to subscribe hit
the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time